torture rape an excessive use of force
these are just some of the allegations
levelled at sedan security forces in the
new report by us-based NGO physicians
for Human Rights the group has been
investigating the massacre of peaceful
demonstrators in the capital khartoum on
June 3rd last year the security forces
used extreme violence to disperse ISA 10
protesting against the military
governments that took over after the
ousting of dictator Omar havasu more
than 240 people were killed and many
more injured the report details the
alleged abuses and says their actions
were premeditated let's go talk to
Adrian freaky physicians for Human
Rights expert consultant and lead author
of the report hello Elian nice to have
you onboard so you saying that the
attack on Sudan's
true democracy supporters was all
planned by the security forces tell us
more
well in order for thousands of troops in
uniform bearing whips sticks batons and
guns to converge in one small area from
different sides it requires a fairly
high level of logistical planning well
there are many questions that need to be
answered on the ground in Sudan I think
that no one argues with the fact that
organization is required to move that
many humans in coordination into one
space ok so how did you arrive at these
findings
well the findings were based on a wide
range of research but the most critical
is that of interviews with survivors of
the violence on June 3rd as well as
treating physicians who describe not
only the injuries but also the special
animus that they were subjected to by
the attackers many of whom said things
like you doctors are the reason that
people are dying and you are the reason
that we kill it's also notable that many
hospitals were attacked and that
patients and injured people were unable
to access care on that day now this is a
very serious reset for sure
that government be given the chance to
respond or have they responded in any
way the government has received the
report the Minister of Justice and the
Attorney General as well as of course
the Commission and they have confirmed
receipt of the report and they have
emphasized that the Commission's mandate
has been extended and will be fully
supported so here's the thing most of
the time such reports come out a lot of
research goes into it and then such
findings are released but there are no
replications what are the possible
replications with this one such a great
question I think one important fact is
that the National Commission is fully
owned by the transitional government in
Sudan and our report is really to
support its work so it's a critical part
of the negotiated transition so I think
it's likely to require political action
the other important thing to realize is
that history has taught us that
transitional justice does not succeed
without accountability so what's the way
for from here
I think the way forward is to develop
and strengthen the human rights
mechanisms that are already in place in
Sudan which is a country full of immense
human talent and very talented lawyers
and committed human rights activists as
well as a mobilized civilian base I
think that within the international
community we have to support that okay
Adrian freaky physicians for Human
Rights experts consultant and lead
author the report thank you thank you